81% of white evangelicals voted for
Donald Trump in the previous election.
That's a record that's more white
evangelicals than voted for George W.
Bush.
And George W.
Bush was a white evangelical.
This makes no sense to people,
especially when you consider that trump
is not just the most irreligious
president in modern history.
That his entire worldview makes a
mockery of core Christian values like
humility and empathy and care for the
poor,
um,
that this individual who couldn't even
name a single verse in the Bible when
asked to do so,
and yet and yet received a record number
of votes by white evangelicals,
scholars of religion,
normal rational people have been trying
to figure out why,
why,
what happened?
And I think that there's a couple of
things to keep in mind.
Number one,
it's white evangelicals.
81% of white evangelicals voted for
trump,
but 67% of evangelicals of color
supported Hillary Clinton.
Now,
these are people who believe the exact
same thing,
whose only real difference is that is
the color of their skin.
So let's not ignore the fact that there
is a racial element to this support.
Uh,
Jim Wallace,
the head of the sojourners,
a liberal evangelical group said it best
when he said that these white
evangelicals quote acted more white than
they did evangelical.
And I think he's right.
The second reason I think it has to do
with the,
the pernicious influence of something
called the Prosperity Gospel,
which is gripped the imaginations of
white evangelicals.
This is that a version of Christianity
preached by these charlatans like Joel
Olsteen and td Jakes,
the essential just of which is that God
wants you to drive a Bentley.
That what Jesus really wants for you is
material prosperity.
And indeed that's how you know God has
blessed you is by your material
prosperity.
Many white evangelicals looked at Donald
Trump,
and what they saw was a wealthy man.
And that wealth,
as far as they were concerned,
was just a sign of God's blessings.
And so that freed trump from having to
do what every other candidate,
certainly every other Republican
candidate for president has had to do.
And that is actually prove his spiritual
bond.
Bonafides.
Trump never had to do that.
All he had to do was just keep talking
about how rich he was.
And for a large swath of white
evangelicals,
that was enough.
Thirdly,
Donald Trump did something that no other
president,
not even any Republican president
cording the event evangelical vote ever
did.
He Express Lee promised secular power to
these white evangelical groups in his
speeches to them.
And,
and,
and the conferences that he had,
both private and public,
he very clearly and very explicitly said
that if they voted for him,
that he would give them their power
back.
Um,
even if he didn't agree with their pet
causes,
that he would just allow them,
uh,
to have those causes.
And you can see as president,
you know,
he's talking now about removing for
instance,
than Johnson Amendment,
which is an amendment that prohibits a
preachers and churches from actually
engaging directly in politics,
um,
and preaching politics from the pulpit.
It's why they get to keep their,
their tax break.
Uh,
no one has ever thought about,
uh,
removing this requirement until Donald
Trump.
And now he is very seriously,
uh,
moving towards allowing churches to take
part directly in political activism,
um,
as churches.
But none of this,
none of this explains the most important
phenomenon about white evangelicals in
America.
And that is this in the span of a single
election cycle,
white evangelicals have gone from being
the group in America that is most likely
to say that a politician's morality
matters to the group that is now least
likely to say that atheists and America
think that a politician's morality
matters more than white evangelicals in
America do.
White evangelicals who continue to refer
to themselves as value voters.
This is a phenomenon that can't be
explained by just looking at the
Prosperity Gospel or looking at racial
matters.
What you're seeing is a gigantic group
of Americans who are fundamentally
overturning their core theological
beliefs that public morality matters.
And the only explanation that I have for
it is that Donald Trump has turned a
large swath of white evangelical
Christianity into a cult,
into a religious cult,
a dangerous religious cult.
All the signs are there.
Um,
you know,
Donald Trump functions as he himself
admitted when he said offhandedly that
he could shoot someone on fifth avenue
and not lose voters.
He has become a kind of a prophetic
divine character.
Pat Robertson,
the head of the 700 club of very
influential white evangelical,
literally said that God took him in a
dream up to heaven.
And he saw Donald Trump sitting at the
right hand of God.
You know,
who actually sits at the right hand of
God according to Evangelicals,
Jesus Christ.
In other words,
Pat Robertson is saying that Donald
Trump is essentially Jesus Christ.
That that's not that weird.
His Own,
uh,
evangelical advisor,
a pastor by the name of Jeffers,
uh,
said not too long ago that he would
prefer Donald Trump as a candidate over
someone who quote,
she expresses the values of Jesus.
So what we are seeing now is that these
white evangelicals,
not all of them,
but a,
but a fundamental core of them,
have essentially latched onto Donald
Donald Trump as almost a salvific
character.
They don't just follow him.
They don't just agree with him.
They almost worship him.
And my fear is that as we know from our
very recent history,
uh,
colts,
when confronted with the realities of
the world can often and in catastrophic
ways,
we have a presidency that is
deteriorating,
a president that is spiraling out of
control.
We have open conversations now about the
25th amendment and impeachment.
We have multiple investigations and the
possibility of indictments at the
highest level.
This is a presidency that is in danger
of completely disintegrating.
That wouldn't be such a big deal if it
weren't also a religious cult.
Because when a religious cult begins to
deal with this kind of situation,
when they're cosmic ideas are,
are suddenly butting up against the
reality,
uh,
of,
of a failed a leadership,
they tend to double down.
And that's why I think that we're in a
very dangerous place as a country right
now,
because the only thing more dangerous
than a cult leader like trump is a
martyred cult leader.
Mm.